and the support from the polish
community here in las vegas is growing
with many doing what they can to show
support victoria saha caught up with
some of them tonight bringing us their
story victoria
brian those i spoke with today say they
are devastated to see the images of
ukrainians being forced to flee from
their home country but are so proud
poland is welcoming them in with open
arms
as many flee by cars trains and foot the
polish government is making sure
ukrainians know they have their back
they
scare you and they try to
understand that
freedom is not free yolanda gorka works
at pierogi village she has been in las
vegas for 18 years but still has family
back in poland although poland is
welcoming ukrainian refugees she is
scared her native country may be the
next target for russia's president
vladimir putin it's like the
you know nevada and california but all
she can do is help her friends on the
front line she reads as a list of things
they desperately need medication
water disinfection water over at polish
deli we spoke with the vice president of
the polish american social club of las
vegas by donating honey absolutely it
helps a lot of organizations she says
her parents are looking to take in
refugees into their home my dad was born
in 36 so he remembers world war ii he
says you know this brings you know
memories a community hoping and praying
for peace from thousands of miles
away those women i spoke with say poland
is not leaving any refugees stranded
they're holding a prayer service
tomorrow evening at our lady of las
vegas church if you would like to donate
to one of their organizations to help
ukrainians we'll have those links up on
our website at 8 news now dot com denise
back to you
victoria thank you so